un carrusel de las artes maría carolina
piña
[Música]
le damos la bienvenida a este carrusel
de las artes una vez más desde el
festival de cannes edición número 74 del
festival de cine más grande del mundo
donde hemos visto una lluvia de
estrellas y de creadores del séptimo
arte
[Música]
les contaremos lo mejor de la primera
semana del festival de cannes 2021 y la
lluvia de estrellas que han desfilado
por la cual set la película mexicana la
civil recibió un largo aplauso en cannes
la cinta de más de dos horas de duración
aborda el tema del secuestro en un país
aquejado por la violencia y el abandono
de las instituciones fuimos también a
las secciones paralelas para ver una
cinta uruguaya y una española presentes
en la quincena de los realizadores y la
semana de la crítica
[Música]
el festival de cine de cannes se
desarrolla este año en medio de un
caluroso verano aquí en francia pero las
altas temperaturas no han afectado el
desfile frenético de estrellas por la
alfombra roja al contrario a pesar del
calor y del cob y de cannes sigue siendo
por estos días la meca del cine de autor
nos lo cuenta
melissa bar
[Música]
el público los esperaba con ansias y la
mayoría cumplió su cita en la alfombra
roja empezando por la aclamada jodie
foster 45 años después de que la
película de martin scorsese taxis riders
que la reveló al mundo ganará la palma
de oro en cannes la actriz
estadounidense recibió en 2021 de la
mano de pedro almodovar la palma de
honor por su brillante carrera
[Música]
otra gran mujer del séptimo arte en
pisar la alfombra roja fue catherine
denueve fue recibida con ovación en la
sala donde se proyectaba su última
interpretación de su vivo de la francesa
emmanuel bajo la misma sala donde en
1965 se proyectó le paga pizza wood de
jacques demy su primer gran éxito que
cosechó una palma de oro su regreso este
año a la alfombra roja marca también una
victoria para la superestrella francesa
quien sufrió problemas de salud un ictus
en 2019 puso su trabajo entre paréntesis
[Música]
y también fue ovacionado incluso escalas
lágrimas y muy emocionado de volver a
ver las salas llenas
damon presento stillwater cuestión de
sangre sobre un taladrador
estadounidense que viaja a marsella para
intentar liberar de cárcel a su hija
john payne presentó su último bus como
cineasta y actor frank day hizo la
alfombra roja con su y hardy land quien
interpreta a la autora del libro que
penn lleva a la pantalla una historia
sobre un padre estafador en los años 70
y 80
una cara que brilló por su ausencia fue
la de la actriz francesa léase du quien
dio positiva a la cob y de este año en
el que protagoniza cuatro cintas en la
competencia incluida la muy esperada del
french dispatch de wes anderson de
friends dispares cuyo elenco causó gran
sensación en el público con su llegada
en autobús a la alfombra roja
[Música]
por otro lado el delegado general del
festival thierry frémaux desmintió
rumores sobre un posible foco de
contagio en cannes y recordó que entre
las 2500 pruebas que se realizaron sólo
tres han dado positivo
la primera semana de cannes trajo
también su dosis de polémica de la mano
del francés biomar mike quien interpreta
a un camionero y chaleco amarillo en la
cinta la factura de katyn coaching la
prensa retuvo un extracto de la rueda de
prensa en la que el actor declaró querer
romperle la cara al presidente de manuel
marco y aunque se trataba de un diálogo
de la película causó gran indignación en
la clase políticos más de
el festival de cine de cannes es también
una importante vitrina para el cine
hablado en español con películas que se
proyectan en las distintas secciones del
festival vos podes prestarme 3000 pesos
no se mueve por
por qué
una película mexicana arrancó nutridos
aplausos aquí en cannes la civil de la
directora rumana teodora and a mi hija y
se proyectó en la selección una cierta
mirada la civil es una cinta conmovedora
y durísima sobre una madre que busca a
su hija secuestrada por un cartel ante
el inmovilismo y el desdén de las
autoridades cielo decide llevar su
propia investigación asociándose a un
militar con métodos poco ortodoxos que
la lleva a una espiral de violencia no
la dejan bajo la tiene secuestrada la
película está basada en una historia
real que la directora rumana teodora and
amijai escuchó en la voz de una víctima
una madre mexicana que buscaba a su hija
secuestrada que tenga un bonita noche
su nombre miriam rodríguez estaba
buscando a su hija y desafortunadamente
se volvió muy famosa y no por los buenos
motivos porque fue asesinada en el 2017
en el día de la madre en mexico
entonces ella el encuentro con ella en
el 2015 fue muy impactante para mí y la
señora miriam nos dijo una cosa que nos
impactó tanto que dio la idea de
inspirar el personaje del cielo sobre
ella nos dijo cuando abro los ojos que
siento
ganas de matar o ganas de morirme la
persona que me estaba ayudando
pues esa persona
no existe lo que el groso que es esto
la famosa actriz mexicana arcelia
ramírez acompañada de álvaro guerrero
interpretan a los padres que remueven
cielo y tierra para encontrar a su hija
pues desde que leí el guión me pareció
un guión muy poderoso y un personaje muy
emocionante porque es un personaje que
empieza en un lugar y termina en otro
totalmente distinto me sentí también muy
responsabilizada porque por desgracia es
un problema es una situación trágica que
viven muchísimas mujeres en méjico ella
entra en un círculo de violencia en
donde de ser víctima se vuelve
victimaria no eso por un lado y por otro
lado también creo que la película habla
de
pues como de la emancipación de una
mujer de que no nada más tomar la
justicia en la búsqueda de su hija por
su propia mano sino también su propia
vida
el hecho de suponer cómo viven los
padres y una madre como tú deseas que se
encuentra sola ante el mundo cómo se
puede vivir eso la pérdida de un hijo de
no saber en dónde está no a la mejor tal
vez si si supiera que está muerta si
pudiera hacerle el velorio el duelo
sería más tranquilizado pero no sabe
dónde está
viva
yo creo que si tienes una madre si sabes
lo que es amor
la quincena de los realizadores
selección paralela del festival de
cannes presentó el empleado y el patrón
una cinta que nos lleva al campo entre
uruguay y brasil
un joven terrateniente debe contratar a
un muchacho del campo casi de su edad
quien necesita alimentar a su familia un
terrible accidente en la plantación
acerca a estos dos hombres el director
manuel nietos/as explora aquí dos mundos
muy distintos y muestra la realidad de
la vida rural le preguntamos qué le
atrae del campo
quería contar la relación entre estos
dos personajes
que como característica principal es que
son muy jóvenes
me gustaba eso como trabajar sobre este
universo joven haciéndose adulto ver
cómo cambiaba esta relación la gente la
ve como una película política en
términos de lucha de clases
alguien dijo marxista por ahí
yo me inclino por decir que puede ser
hegel jana pero
es
jajaja
la cinta está protagonizada por el actor
argentino nahuel pérez biscayart quien
se acudió a cannes en 2017 con la
película francesa 120 latidos por minuto
esta vez el público francés lo descubre
en una cinta hablada en español que lo
llevó a un país cercano pero diferente
contó vuelva con helado y contó
voy a descubrir algo realmente nuevo que
parecía cercano pero no lo era
y manolo tiene todo eso tiene tiene esa
mirada tiene el campo tiene la ciudad
tiene tiene el rock
y tiene bombachas de campo y hay algo de
eso que no sé fue muy bonito y muy
inspirador y muy difícil también porque
es al alser sutilmente diferente demanda
mucha más atención
en la selección paralela a la semana de
la crítica se proyectó la cinta española
libertad de la catalana clara roquetas
[Música]
la cinta nos acerca al despertar a la
adolescencia de dos chicas nora y
libertad durante unas vacaciones de
verano no ahora 15 años pasa sus
vacaciones en casa de su abuela allí
conoce a libertad un adolescente de su
edad que acaba de llegar de colombia
para estar con su madre quien trabaja
como empleada en esa casa la historia de
amistad de las chicas se entremezcla con
los conflictos personales que viven los
otros personajes a la vez que se explora
la complicada relación entre madres e
hijas es una película muy bella que como
dices habla de muchas cosas tienen
muchas capas como la vida misma como las
familias y aparte de la historia más
troncal que es un poco el despertar a la
libertad de esta adolescente que quiere
romper un poco con este vínculo tan
heavy con la madre a la vez tan bonito
que tenemos cuando somos pequeños pero
lo necesario que es también de romperlo
y le aparece este personaje
esta chica colombiana hermosa que se
llama libertad que también tiene su
problema con su madre porque tuvo que
venir aquí como tantas mujeres
a trabajar y dejándola de pequeñita que
también le abre un poquito la vida y la
mira al personaje que es cómo te va
entrando desde la luz hasta que te
agarra el corazón y te emociona
[Música]
la magnética libertad interpretada por
la colombiana nicole garcia suscita el
interés de nora a pesar de las
diferencias de clase y de cultura la
joven actriz maría morera
yo vivía un poco eso también como norah
porque yo y nicole vivíamos juntas
durante el rodaje y bueno que ella me
fuera contando cómo era su vida pues era
muy diferente a la mía no pero bueno
también la película habla de eso que el
amor pues da igual de qué clase social
seas de del entorno que si hay amor y
hay amistad pues eso es lo que importa
al final
[Música]
libertad de clara roquet estuvo en la
competencia para cámara de oro a la
mejor película del festival de cine de
cannes
cuando se ven muy felices aquí todos
estos veranos
[Música]
así
aquí ponemos punto final este programa
especial que les presentamos desde el
corazón del festival de cannes y desde
ya le damos cita para la próxima semana
un último carrusel de las artes desde el
festival más prestigioso del mundo a
favor
[Música]
ah